[Musique]
park
pb à paroles autochtone si ces
médicaments long du puits cette semaine
je ne peux pas passer à côté des
déclarations de nos premiers ministres
de suivre go ces déclarations vous là
qu'il a de la misère à s'imaginer
pouvoir donner un droit de veto aux
communautés autochtones et aussi pouvoir
appliquer la déclaration des droits des
peuples autochtones
bien sûr le canada ont reconnu la
déclaration des droits des peuples
autochtones en 2010 ça a d'ailleurs été
un des derniers pays à l'avoir fait de
peine et de misère
pourquoi parce que ça implique
énormément de reconnaître ces
déclarations là c'est pas une
déclaration pour les réserves ou pour la
loi sur les indiens on parle de tous les
peuples autochtones
un peu partout dans le monde hélas au
canada ça veut dire les premières
nations les premières nations non
inscrits sous la loi sur les indiens et
aussi les inuits et les métis
donc c'est reconnaître cette déclaration
a surtout au canada où on a fait de la
colonisation de bonne foi ça dit on a eu
des traités on a eu des ententes avec
les communautés ou ou si on a eu des
droits n'ont cédé ça peut vouloir dire
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de travail de
la part des gouvernements
autrefois c'était plus fédérale puisque
c'est notre premier interlocuteur entre
nous et la reine mais aujourd'hui ça
veut aussi dire le provincial et même le
municipal et les complications que cela
mène pour le gouvernement
je comprends que monsieur legault ne
veut pas avoir à avoir à faire un droit
de veto de la part des communautés
autochtones
je pense que ça résonne beaucoup avec
aussi sa déclaration comme quoi il n'ya
pas de racisme le systémique au québec
et bien malheureusement c'est une preuve
à cet ange et que grâce à la loi sur les
indiens grâce à la colonisation grâce
justement à 7
ce droit de veto de sa part de pouvoir
reconnaître que les autochtones ont des
droits ou non de vouloir les appliquer
ou non
eh bien ça prouve vraiment qu'il y a un
système qui est raciste a dit que basée
sur la race et sur l'identité et que
l'on veut par ce passage très doux ne
pas reconnaître la déclaration des
peuples autochtones continuer la
colonisation d'une façon au dos on veut
pouvoir reconnaître que les autochtones
ont des droits on veut pouvoir
reconnaître que l'heure passée a été
difficile on veut reconnaître les
pensionnats les femmes assassinées et
disparues
cependant entre reconnaître et se
réconcilier
et aussi réparer l'erreur et la douleur
qui a été faite le l'engagement est un
peu plus timide alors vous pouvez voir
comment ils sont pris entre l'arbre et
les corses
pour ce qui est des questions des
communautés autochtones cependant quand
on entend ces déclarations alors on
n'entend qu'eux on veut pas faire avoir
à faire un parti d'opposition qu'on
parle de la pnq l on parle pas d'un
parti d'opposition parlent de
représentants de communautés autochtones
qui ont des enjeux qui leur sont propres
qui leur sont d'ailleurs très diversifié
et donc la responsabilité des
gouvernements et d'écouter les
problématiques
cependant si on entend c'est comme voir
encore un groupe d'autochtones acquis et
on se pose
je comprends que madame dame en
difficulté à pouvoir aller de l'avant
avec les discussions parce qu'en plus on
va mettre dans la balance les
communautés autochtones qui sont se
réserve donc qui sont sous la loi sur
les indiens qui ont affaire à la
politique fédérale d'assimilation mais
on oublie aussi que son petit ce qu'on
attend dans les milieux urbains soit
avec les centres d'amitié avec les
organismes qui protègent les droits des
communautés autochtones dans les milieux
urbains qui ne sont pas des réserves
alors en faisant un gros tas pont et je
deviens tapant d'automne et bien c'est
sûr qu'on veut pas on veut pas avoir à
faire face à tout ça mais
malheureusement il faut le faire il faut
démêler les noeuds qui ont été faites
dans les droits dans les les enjeux les
communautés autochtones
il faut reconnaître que ces droits là je
ne sais même pas si symbolique ce n'est
pas juste une réconciliation symbolique
qu'il faut faire c'est une
réconciliation véritable et ça va
demander du travail tels que monsieur
legault ne sera pas la personne qui va
le faire mais ne pas vouloir reconnaître
ses droits là ce sont des droits qui
sont soutenus par le gouvernement
canadien
c'est vraiment de vouloir éviter d'avoir
à payer la facture d'avoir à faire le
travail et aussi d'avoir à écouter des
enjeux qui qui remonte à quand même
longtemps et qui n'ont pas été pris au
sérieux par les gouvernements qu'ils
soient fédéral provincial ou municipal
donc vous pouvez comprendre que c'est
encore une fois beaucoup de travail
les communautés elles ne lâcheront pas
parce que c'est une question quand même
de bien née
de survie de santé la sécurité des
femmes toutes ces enjeux-là sont compris
dans la déclaration des droits des
peuples autochtones donc vous pouvez
imaginer qu'on se fait dire non on
reconnaît pas on veut pas de l'appliquer
parce que ça va vous donner un droit de
veto c'est à dire qu'on va se parler de
nation à nation est bien là je comprends
la frayeur ouhlala la frilosité de nos
représentant gouvernemental
donc je vous encourage à l'est la lire
la déclaration sur les droits des
peuples autochtones
je vous encourage tous à aller découvrir
la déclaration parce qu'ils m'ont à la
décoration la constitution canadienne
l'article 35 qui reconnaît les droits
ancestraux des communautés autochtones
et peut-être commencé à découvrir la
ligne de droit qui n'a jamais été coupé
entre nos territoires
notre droit d'exister sur nos
territoires justement est de pouvoir
pêcher chasser de pouvoir faire du
commerce
jusqu'à aujourd'hui du début de la
colonisation jusqu'à aujourd'hui
donc bon exploration et je vous souhaite
une bonne semaine